senator paul
there is no such thing as gain of
function research
now there might be
a uh increase
of
utility
inquiry yeah yeah we yeah we might do
some of that but there is a no longer
any such thing as gain of function
research because i told people to stop
using that phrase are you aware of that
we're aware that you deleted gain of
function from the nih website well uh
okay we can
talk about that maybe a little later
there's no reason to bring up websites
or or people covering things up or
changing anything what i what we need to
drive home here is that gain of function
is not something that any of us have
ever ever done eco health alliance took
the virus
you're saying that that's not gain of
function research all right look i'm
sorry about the beagles so what you're
doing is defining away gain of function
you're simply saying it doesn't exist
because you changed the definition on
the nih website why don't you just shut
up huh
i want you to think back over the past
90 days how often did you eat a little
too much
drink a little too much or spend too
much time in the office
how many times did you ignore your wife
children or friends
just to thumb through social media like
netflix
youtube or a game how many hours did you
waste doom scrolling through the
headlines so many men today are
distracted they are dependent on the
comforts of this world making them
incapable of even knowing they aren't
free to say no to those things guys we
were made for more than this
if you desire freedom from those
attachments freedom to be a better
husband a better father and a better man
for others i invite you to check out
exodus 90.com
michael exodus 90 is a 90-day program
that gets us back to the fundamentals of
the faith prayer self-denial and
fraternity more than 50 000 men from
around the world have done this
99 report experiencing greater freedom
check it out for yourself at exodus 90
dot com slash michael exodus nine zero
dot com slash michael